[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen dear conference
members
thank you very much for giving
me in this conference who focus so much
on technical solutions
and excellent communication a window of
solidarity
to humanitarian crisis caused by the
awful war in the ukraine
we heard this very personal statement
and i'm sure you could speak much better
than me about the effects to your family
and your friends so i only will give the
speech as a austrian staying in austria
but being in touch with many people in
the ukraine and trying to organize help
to them
so many people
lost their futures within the first
moments
this war started a nightmare for so many
but it also shows us a lot of solidarity
here in europe
i'm personally touched by the phone
calls with my colleagues in the ukraine
who are sitting in an air ride shelter
while being on phone or laptop and
coordinating help
our colleagues who evacuate whole
orphanages overnight and organize still
children use groups
where it is needed
our project partners who stay shoulder
and shoulder with volunteers to read
back food medical devices or other
needed goods to distribute them to
people in destroyed villages and cities
i admire all the groups of people who
welcome arriving refugees day and night
at the border and host and serve them
later in their private homes
so many people spend their time over
their infrastructures and often risk
life to help others
our austrian-based ngo huge dynavelt
doesn't leave these people alone our
network of dombosco organizes its active
about 80 countries around the world we
support community development programs
schools street children programs as well
as educational and technical training
courses in countries of the so-called
global south
education overcomes poverty is what we
believe and work to promote it
in the event of a humanitarian crisis or
a war like now in ukraine we do
everything we can to stand with our
experienced partners and friends
our tombosco partners
we mainly cooperate with are usually
active on the spots since many decades
ready to act in any moment
they know the local conditions and they
rely on the large number of volunteers
even now
our human eval networks maintains 12
locations within the ukraine and many
others along the borders like in poland
slovakia and the river republic of
moldova
two major centres in ukraine are
supplied by us with essentials for
people in the area
at in the beginning it was leaf lamborgh
and recently there is a growing concern
that the situation in odessa is getting
worse
drugs regularly bring relief goods
across the border to supply the centers
with the most needed material
about 200 employees are still working in
the facilities in ukraine which are
supported by many volunteers during this
difficult hours
they all decided to stay in a dangerous
environment to help
gunfire as we heard bombs syrians
uncertainty
what comes up accompanies them
i was touched when i heard
how tons of bread is being packed day by
day in live and brought inland by train
and cars to be distributed to other
centers
however what we offer is not only
materialistic things or financial aid to
people in need
but what is much more important for
people is that they know they are not
left alone
it is important that people connect with
them and accompany them on their first
escape or welcome them later in safe
neighbor countries
our local partners within the ukraine
risk their life to ensure that others
receive the help they need
i am so grateful that still so many
motivated people from our network are
offering guidance and assistance
and i'm very grateful for every
financial support we receive as ngo to
help the people of the ukraine now and
tomorrow
this crisis will not end soon you said
it already it will become worse create
also other crises like hunger crisis in
countries far away who in the future
will not get the expected amount of corn
from the one of the worldwide leading
exporters of this living spending good
we and many other ngos working in the
so-called hunger countries already fear
the situation of lack of food and
prepare us for what could come as much
as possible
but what we need would be food
four weeks ago i visited our educational
programs in ecuador
even there people are dealing with the
effects of this war especially bananas
and roses from ecuador can not longer be
sold to crime and russia
and
workers from the farms there are losing
their jobs and their only income
this war has also an impact to the most
remote corners to the world
but we also feel a heartbreaking
international solidarity of our partners
only one example
the community farmers in one of our
small agricultural farms in uganda came
together and decided as a village to
sell one of the few cows they have and
donate the money to help the ukraine war
refugees what an example
i'm very grateful to our donors
foundations and companies with their
support
they show us and they motivate us to not
leave behind people in need
dear conference participants please
become also partner of our humanitarian
aid program
if you are not already engaged in others
or support andre who need really the
staff to improve and
to improve the network he has
please help also in the humanitarian
sector and if you do not have any
resources to spend
perhaps you have also such a good like a
cow you could sell and spend the capture
you get
while i'm standing on the stage a big
truck with life spending goods is being
loaded and will be on his way to odessa
soon your contribution make this
possible and made others activities too
several of my colleagues are there on
our stand as we heard please come and
visit us we will give more information
on what we are doing
i hope to see you there and stay healthy
optimistic and stay and enjoy your stay
in vienna life goes on
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you